[Music]
do you guys get excited when you see
squirrels or just me
i love squirrels i love those girls dude
everybody
squirrel they're so cute and then uh you
know that um
the uh the dog character from up when
he's like squirrel yeah that's literally
me
i like school every time i see a
squirrel how about chipmunks oh they're
all all the fluffy i don't know i've
never seen a chip they run with their
tail up
what is it they have chipmunks running
around everywhere well when i went
camping
yeah the uh chipmunks they get really
close
and then they freaking sprint with their
tail like it's they got this little tail
like
a little black yeah they're so cute yeah
i've never seen a chipmunk in real life
it's pretty [ __ ] cute
oh super cute okay so this story here
it takes place in ohio and so with
michael
this 35 year old hobbyist who has a
youtube channel where he
chronicles his woodworking
stuff because he likes to just do
woodworking he's a carpenter
i guess that's what you would call it
carpenter huh isn't carpenters just for
like building homes or is it
nothing anything with wood jesus was a
carpenter
yeah or his dad carpenter he does not
use a like electrical saw though
he didn't have it back then he would
suck now jesus would master
pretty quickly though do you think so i
think so so michael here
he was talking to his neighbor one day
who his neighbor
bird watches this
neighbor bird watcher i feel like bird
watchers
are all part-time perverts oh with a
good excuse to use
binoculars but then they also look at
girls showering
and they get caught they're like oh
that's a [ __ ] uh red toe sparrow
oh i never thought about that peeping
top blue jay
that's a boobay
that's funny well it's not a male it's a
female bird watching she can be nasty
too
yeah well so she was talking to michael
that's a penis
michael about how she bird watches with
her daughter
and then she told him that there were
just all these squirrels that kept
getting in the way
like get out of the way they kept eating
like the bird feed that they were
leaving out for the birds
nothing not the bird
you gotta give it back for it do it it's
just my this is taika he likes saying
nazi nazi bad
i don't know why i don't even know what
it is in a british accent yeah
i gotta hear this that's probably from a
show and our fans gonna
let you know where it's from yeah that
is nice yeah so adorable
okay so then after michael heard this
from his neighbor
he was like thing idea i'm gonna create
something
with my word working skills so he
created
the cutest [ __ ] thing ever which is a
squirrel bar
a a nutty bar ah tight so this
is what it is look at that oh my god
that is professional
and then there's like a restroom sign
and it says wow
squirrely look at this oh my gosh
so the restroom side is like nuts that
way no nuts that way
and then each nut is like it says cashew
cashew dunkle peanut pilsner almond
ale oh pistachio peel pistachio pale
ale walnut stouts uh i can't read the
other ones
how do you think they get the nuts out
pecan porter
i can't read that one oh yeah no look
you can see they like
like this today i'm going to have a
turn i freaking love seeing this yeah
that's true and they use their little
hands they're like
what's the ones that put it inside and
they hide and they go run away squirrels
yeah these guys they could stuff
like a [ __ ] ton of nuts in their mouth i
think it's funny the nuts no nuts
yeah yeah that's right that's just being
a sign in a regular my favorite part
about this whole thing so he created
this entire
nutty bar and then he just set it up in
in his neighbor's backyard
and then he just waited to see her
reaction what if squirrels get into a
bar fight over here i know
right start beating each other up
sliding them across the counter you need
a squirrel but
a bouncer chipmunk bouncer bouncers yes
he needs to get paid to do this for a
lot of other people i think people want
it
people want it that should be a real bar
though yeah that would be a real bar
look at all those nuts in there
oh sunflower size zones seasons
oh my god you know what i wish i had
cool skills like that
no i saw this and i'm like uh i took a
woodworking
class in high school when i was a i
think a junior
and i made something i forgot what i
made already but just working with the
wood i'm like this is so fun i really
loved it
but that was the only time i ever did it
and i think that's like it
it fed into my love for like
crafting and like working with my hands
handiwork with handiwork and because i
love
power tools i really love that [ __ ] i
don't actually make anything
but it reminded me of those days and i'm
like man i wonder how different my life
would have been if i would have pursued
word work
i took a welding class welding was fun
i've always wanted to learn how to weld
too you feel badass with that torch
nelson over here built me a gym rack oh
yeah really
that's a real man oh he's hella handy
yeah super
he builds his own like door i'm
motorcycle i'm
so fascinated with people that can build
their own [ __ ] i think that is so dope i
could build my own food
yeah shout out to oh i saw uh papa tone
papatown and mamadina
uh their family they went and built a
whole
like extended area like with the whole
overhang with the proper roofing
and they built like a greenhouse in
their backyard and then built like a
shed
apartment situation in the backyard and
literally everything you could think of
he built and fixed his cars and they got
the whole setup in the garage who's this
uh we just call him papa tone and
mamadina papatone can fix anything
anything and he can make everything so i
was like uh by the way i'm gonna employ
you one day because oh i thought you're
gonna say like oh you got a son
he does have a son you have a daughter
but going back to it he built like they
can build so much stuff and fix cars and
do all that i've always thought that
that was the dopest thing for people
that can build and be
build some [ __ ] sure there's no way like
if i had to i couldn't even put up my
damn ikea
uh little i loved tv it was i mean i
could but did i get
true joy i didn't i don't know but then
i just painted my whole thing my house
right and i was telling bart that
usually i would have paid somebody to do
should have had me come over yes
but there's a difference in me putting
the work into it and now it feels like
my place that i'm going to create
yeah and that's true and now i'm going
to design it with my buddy
and i'm like oh you know what now it
finally feels like my space that i'm
going to create it's going to personal
well that's cool when you
cuz i painted your room before i
remember that was fun but didn't we both
do it no that was all you that was
obviously that's fun when you when
you're like in your own zone and you're
like now i'm going to make this into
what it should be
it's just like a whole you just reflect
on oh no i'm not there yet
like i said ikea and i we like we've
been putting [ __ ] together but you know
that [ __ ] gonna break down but it's
also you're in an apartment because i
know that feeling
it's like it's temporary yeah right and
then this is
my friend's place so i also want to make
it better right it's not just a rental
investing the time because i went in i
started fixing all the little
like he had cracks and stuff and i had
like glue and i was like i'm a paint
over this fix it
everything looks so much better oh yeah
i can't wait to have a backyard again i
want a backyard and i want like a
chicken
so i can get my eggs from there i mean i
really can't grow
[ __ ] for [ __ ] but you know like i want
to pretend that i actually can grow
something we just finished our backyard
yeah but if there's no
grass or anything we just put cement
everywhere
but we do want to have pots and grow our
own plants
and see if we can actually like keep it
alive
yeah i wanted lemon tree ugly i love it
i love it i think joe had a lemon tree
i did i wrote him and said can i have
lemons from your lemon tree
i probably sound like i'm hitting on him
every [ __ ] time i write can i go with
you with to go see the mushrooms if i'm
like damn this [ __ ] is thirsty
dad you want to see my mushrooms my
mushroom and these lemons when life
gives you
lemons you get nikki
but i think it's so dope that's amazing
it's probably hella boys now that are
deemed i gotta let my tree i got a lemon
tree i can cook
i like candy melts speaking of lemons
there's a this is right there
they've been listening they've been
listening they're like damn this girl
really likes like
lemons so we don't give her something
there's a lot of things you can do with
lemons
why why does that saying even exist like
it's a negative thing when life gives
you lemons [ __ ] you could do a lot with
lemon i love
lemons you can clean your house with
lemons that's why you can make lemonade
you can make lemonade and you can yeah
yeah
lemon popsicles but they say it as if
it's a bad thing like when life
gives you lemons they don't have a
saying like when life gives you money
well that's well i guess i'll spend it
that's
your negative connotation on life when
life gives you lemons like when life
just gives you right you ever heard when
life gives you lemons and a positive
it's because it's sour
it's like when life gives you lemons
make lemonade like make it into a
possibility
they call they call beat down broken
cards
lemon because it's sour it's lemons are
like negative
but i love them power stuff is the best
stuff i do do you guys eat lemon peels
what they have to do organic like heels
not exactly
sour even no have you had better like
the candy
yeah like lemon peel orange peel i think
that's why you're single lemon peel
because
you've never had first off
she eats weird if you guys saw the other
episode of the weird [ __ ] they was
eating
yeah did you notice i didn't participate
in the weird food conversation turtle
boy that's true
turtle this ninja turtle over here you
soup
turtles i just picture her eating the
peel and throwing away them
we've never had dehydrated lemon peels
like candy see
we got one person nobody else knows what
i'm talking about like it's like
not the peel we they have like dried
they soak it in sugar
or like yeah yeah like that yeah like
candied
yeah so whenever you make like a raw
pizza like a fresh lemon peel because
growing up we had like a lemon tree but
it was like organic and you can you
literally take a bite out of the lemon
okay so we have like liji moy seeds so
likes uh
yeah i like those but they have like
orange peel lemon peel and it's with the
humid powder on it and they
dehydrate the lemons and then they go
and you have them in a package and you
just eat them like you like salty [ __ ]
you'd be addicted to it
i can't give you that you actually have
an addictive person a real addiction
but yeah that stuff is good yeah okay i
want a nut bar
yes back to my nutmeg so
he posted a video of his his build
process of the nutty bar and he said
that he was
overwhelmed with comments and requests
to purchase
this bar so he immediately designed i
mean
immediately applied for a design patent
and he's now
planning to launch a business to sell
the nutty box
for about 175 to 200. yeah nice
you guys want a squirrel nutty bar hit
them up
i ain't got no that would be cool to
just have in your house too because the
names are if you like
at your bar because you can have all
your little peanut
pull it out it's a snacks a human nut
bar michael if you want to send us one
a nut bar you know we got a p.o box i
don't want five three
send to monterey park california nine
one
seven five four send two and then send
one for nikki
thank you i want your nut bar send me
your nut bar
that's gonna be a whole nother thing
then be like i made nut bars
[Music]
foreign